now there's a woman who
frankly i know there are a lot of people
up for the republican nomination for
president
this woman if she wants it i think she
has my endorsement i think she has my
vote she put the situation here with
biden and the kovid mandates and his
patience wearing thin she put it better
than just about anyone i've heard
talking about my patience is wearing
thin what are you talking to
as long as your patients don't get as
thin as that hairline i think will be
all right i am not your child
and i'm showing up natural
you're talking about your patience is
wearing this these people have lost they
acting like they you know what i'm
saying i'm saying like they paying your
bills and you down you got to watch
saw that little clip i said oh he's
crazy
he really think he you really think i
miss her
my patience is wearing thin i need you
to get out on that boulevard and bring
me my money yeah my pimp
the hell is wrong with these people he
really said that [ __ ] out of his mouth
but our patience is wearing thin you
bald hip see see
see i'm trying i thank god see that
danny calling me right now trying to
save kind of saved my mind
i could not have said it better myself
and i think that on a deep level maybe
people use slightly different words
that's the feeling of a lot of americans
who are not going to pay any attention
to that
where do i vote for that woman where do
i give me a mail-in ballot so i can vote
for that woman for something
i'm so glad that you like that clip that
makes me feel good if you want to leave
me a comment that'd be great
you can also go to the michael knowles
show at apple podcast spotify stitcher
wherever you get your podcast just right
now pull out that phone pull it out let
me see i got i got mine here pull up
your podcast app type in the michael
knowles show subscribe
really appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you